good morning bachelor nation thank you
so much for joining us here on roses and
Rose a live i'm lauren zima joined by
katie crowd thanks for having me Katie I
had to have you because everybody Katie
Kraus is a woman with an opinion oh yeah
and we have just learned this morning
our new bachelor announced on Good
Morning America spoiler alert all that
you probably know by now everybody it is
should we say it together three two one
Colton so Katie and I have so much to
say about the new bachelor choice
everybody of course bachelor nation has
a lot to say you guys have a lot to say
we want to know your comments your
thoughts your reactions opinions
questions leave them on et social
platforms we will get them here on the
iPad and we've got a lot to break down
because Wow first of all let's just
watch this moment where Colton was
revealed on gooding Good Morning America
just this morning I think that's you
know that's one thing that I took pride
in on both seasons was just being true
to who I am and I think it took all of
that to get to where I'm at now and know
who I am as a person and know what I
want in a life partner that's cool too
talking about he was kind of asked look
here's what we know Colton was on
Bachelorette with Becca kufran he was
number four on that show he was just on
bachelor in paradise and literally on
Monday night last night you guys if you
missed it we watched Colton dump Tia
booth then this morning he's revealed on
GMA as the new bachelor and he was kind
of giving giving his reasoning there on
why he is ready to be the bachelor
the timing makes sense and that match
allure and Paradise was shot a while ago
so it's not like he actually just broke
up with TLO right night there was a
little bit of wiggle room do I think
he's ready to be the bachelor I think is
the big question that we all have I
don't
I like Colton but he's young he's 26
yeah even before the bachelor the
Bachelorette we knew that he was dating
Aly Raisman then he was dating Becca and
even before that it was Tia and then
again after Tia you're saying basically
you don't think he's been thinking he's
not been single over the past two years
you know what's interesting to me and I
want to play it is a
we just saw him break up with TIA last
night and so that would have been in
about June of this summer so just a
couple months ago and here was the
reasoning that Colton gave Tia about
what she deserves
I just know what you deserve and I can't
give it to you
[Music]
well that's of Tears question for you
yes if he's not ready to give Tia what
she deserves
why is he ready to give someone else
what they deserve that is my question PD
Krauss truly I and that's why I wanted
to play that for you guys because I just
needed more from Colton on the reasoning
behind that breakup like look if you
here's the thing both Colton and Tia I
interviewed Tia after the bachelor in
paradise
tell which taped last week you guys and
that interview with Tia is up now or
going up Rick right now literally DT
online.com and we're actually gonna play
a little piece of you piece of it for
you in a minute but I asked Tia about
you know wide like the break-up how she
felt about it and she said look we both
felt like we tried it's okay if you
tried you gave it a shot and you
realized we're not right for each other
but what does he mean by I couldn't give
her what she deserves I feel like two
there was a point that was missing after
they it took a while for them to kind of
reconcile this season they got together
and it seemed like rainbows and
butterflies what happened I think we we
missed some stuff I don't know it was
weird didn't it it felt like wood they
were the struggle struggle struggle den
they're together and then all of a
sudden he's like nope it's not working I
why I needed to know why it wasn't
working do you think he maybe had these
conversations that he could potentially
be the bachelor even back then I think
that after bachelorette finishes taping
or even close to Yemen as its airing I
think those conversations are being had
so that's potentially possible a hundred
percent it's Oh a lot of comments coming
in from you guys dress-down Shan wants
to know do you think Colton is
emotionally ready to be bachelor with
that so we're talking to you be Bebel
bali el i'm sorry about your name says
personally don't think Colton is the
best choice for the bachelor this season
but the hate he's getting about being
undecided seems unfair there was a lot
of pressure to date Tia well I will say
I think him and Tia were blown out of
proportion because they like went on a
couple dates and then he went on
Bachelorette and it was like I think
they just both needed to cross off or
get into that relationship in their
minds right you know but I do feel like
maybe producers thought there was so
much interest but as I watched at this
season I almost felt like it was too
much Colton and Tia at the beginning I
was like why do why does she get all
these date cards and these people there
that had never gone on a date
still to this day have not gotten a date
card and there was just so much I guess
you're right pressure might be the right
word I don't know that that's an excuse
it's interesting isn't it I mean what we
know is he's 26 yeah he's a virgin
he runs a charity we know he loves dogs
so this is what we know about Colton and
I you brought up so she could point
Katie kind of looking at the ages of
previous bachelors because Ben Higgins
was the youngest bachelor ever he was 26
so Colton is at that same age a lot of
you guys are commenting right now saying
DK three and seventy says maybe ABC
could put Blake or Jason in on night one
and make the girls choose like they did
for Kaitlyn's season Chris Harrison has
told me they will never do that again
and then Rachel said oh my god what
about Blake's so looking at the ages of
Blake and Jason who were the two
runners-up they're both like 28 29 how
much do you think age plays into this I
honestly think it comes down to if you
are totally 100% ready open willing I
don't know that age is the absolute
end-all be-all
do I think 26 is young I do I do think
that guys do mature a little bit slower
than women that's been proven on this
show yeah I'm Jason and Blake I mean
they're what 28 29 so that's to three
year age difference even watching them
on The Bachelorette they seem a little
bit more they're like ready to find a
wife I mean with Colton it is he ready
what's interesting to me is he said on
GMA he's we didn't play this part for
you guys but he said he's ready to get
engaged and married shortly after yeah
so Colton is sitting here saying and I
hears that I didn't need him to say that
yeah I want to say I love this show I
love this franchise I don't need to hear
that people are ready to get married
anymore and here's why when was the last
time we really had like a solid out of
bachelor/bachelorette wedding happen
maybe Sean and Catherine look Kaitlyn
and Shawn Kaitlyn Bristowe Shawn booth
very still not not married still not
married Ben Haines and Lorne bushnell
broke up Nick violin Vanessa broke up
Ari and Lauren are engaged but the thing
is I really look at it at this point as
you're going on the show to potentially
find love the wedding doesn't matter
that
right a fan anymore you know like I
don't need him to say that and it almost
feels like it does put this pressure on
that makes things potentially turn false
at the end
clarissa says 26 is too young Katie take
us through a couple of these for me
Colton and Tia both ended fourth in
their seasons and we're both together in
bachelor in paradise those same journeys
does that mean ts still can be the
Bachelorette Breanna spring into next
year Priya do you think that okay that's
actually a good question if it were time
for a bachelorette season and the roles
were reversed would Tia be ready to be
Bachelorette after ooh interesting Katie
Krause I have to say I lean more towards
TIA being ready I do and they're not
that far off an age but she seems so
much more sure of this relationship
yeah which is I say what you will about
Tia I did appreciate her commitment to
the cause of wanting a relationship yeah
Allison says Colton is such a
good-looking man but I was really hoping
Jason would be the next Bachelor I think
I agree and let's um let's actually talk
through this a little bit because Jason
2829 I think it's always hard to tell
guys the ages that they give us from
like when they're on the shows Jason
really killed it at mental you know he
was bringing the emotion he was saying
all the right things I thought but if
you look at Jason in terms of what kind
of TV he would make again we said
Colton's a virgin Colton former football
player handsome guy picture that face on
a billboard runs a charity jason great
guy a good-looking guy fun I don't know
if he was I mean the storyline for
Colton is on another level so do you
think I know you actually got some
reporting this morning about the yeah
and Colton he does bring the tears he
does bring the drama
I think he's willing to play the game
mm-hmm for lack of a better word do you
think that really was what was being
considered yes so we had some et
reporting come in from a source close to
production just basically telling us
that look yeah Colton's story was a huge
part of this all these factors and that
I look at the end of the day how do you
pass up when is production gonna be
presented with a twenty six-year-old
Virgen Sean Lowe is a born-again virgin
yeah how often are they gonna come
across this you guys well that's a good
point though what do you make of all the
Sean Lowe comparisons because people are
saying he is really similar to Sean Lowe
and aside from Ari he really is the last
successful the only successful bachelor
to come out of this franchise in terms
of marriage they have kids him and
Catherine what do you think of those
comparisons are they fair or are they
unfair I think it's amazing to me how
much this show and kind of our world has
changed in the past couple years Sean
Lowe seems like a world of difference
and sort of a lifetime ago even though
it wasn't that long ago how social media
has changed the shows I mean we were
talking about kind of what everybody
thinks of Colton's intentions like I
mentioned he dated Aly Raisman famous
gymnast before this Beckett iya I'd love
to know not interrupt me I would love to
know what Ali thinks of Colton becoming
the bachelor I think there's a lot to be
said in that she said nothing she said
nothing when he went on The Bachelorette
nothing now that he's been the bachelor
and I think that silence speaks volumes
it's interesting I asked Colton it men
tell all if they'd spoken to me said
they haven't talked since they broke up
so I asked Colton to about like because
look a lot of people were questioning
his intentions T his best friend Raven
came at Colton hard so at the men tell
all taping Bachelorette mental all I
asked him what do you have to say to the
haters here's what Golda said you know
anybody who questions intentions of
going on the show I think for me you
know I put myself out there I was true
to who I was and there was no plotting
there was no scheming it was just me
going on a show and I feel like it was
so good for me to do this and I love
everybody interesting that he told you
sure to who I was the same thing that he
said this morning on GMA but Lauren
thank you thank you to that yeah yeah
and I want your take on this Katie I
just want your reaction cuz you haven't
heard it yet so I mentioned the
interview with Tia from The Bachelor
paradise
tell all taping last week I asked Tia if
she thinks Colton is ready because at
that point we didn't know but I said if
Colton is the bachelor do you think he's
ready for that here's what Tia booth had
to say excited I mean it was just
when did we film that geez I mean it was
just about two months ago that I was
telling him that he really needs to
figure himself out before he can fully
be with someone else so if there's a
chance that Colton is the master I would
hope that he is fully ready for that
experience knowing that he wants to be
engaged do you think he's ready
I vote Jason for Ashley so you don't
think Cole's ready we haven't really had
those conversations since paradise
obviously it's you guys been talking
every day I don't know if he's ready
yeah it's interesting question for you
between the Bachelorette and bachelor in
paradise how much time is there is it
two months yeah well Bachelorette
finishes filming probably around March
and then paradise films in about June
okay once in there okay so now it's been
about two months it'll be three months
probably before the bachelor starts
filming the same amount of time window
mm-hmm do you do you think that's enough
time for him to get to ready himself
here's what I'll say what are these
people doing in that downtime the answer
is not like they're focused on
reflecting on their time on the show
Annelise from bachelor in paradise I
interviewed her recently and she told me
between going on bachelor in paradise
she went to therapy a bunch like so I do
think that you dig into yourself and
these shows you guys really make you
reflect on who you are you don't have
your phone the news a TV anything all
you're doing is thinking about how you
are in relationships all day so do I
think that Colton could have done a lot
of reflecting yes I think that it is
telling though that he has said that but
we should note she did Instagram today
if you can check that out on her
Instagram and she said look it didn't
work out I wish you the best what we do
know is that tee and Colton are very
friendly at this point they're texting a
lot but she said she didn't think he's
ready and she was voting Jason for
Bachelor right interesting um I know
that they've said and he said she will
not appear on his season of The Bachelor
do you think that that will uphold I she
did say that she tweeted she would
definitely not be a contestant which is
such a good idea we're all done with the
Colton into ya story the best laid out
it's done scene
could she appear just like Becca came on
paradise yeah okay I want to get into as
well of course so many of you guys are
saying Alexi says that enough with the
age thing Jason would have been so
boring interesting about Blake
what does anybody out there like Blake I
have those like fans yes because Blake
and Jason definitely producers have
spoken to them about the possibility of
being bachelor I know Blake was a
front-runner for quite a while I think
it started to come down to Colton and
Jason at the end because they both
really again did a great job for lack of
a better term at men tell all
let's look at their instagrams Katie do
you want to take us through Blake
instagramming first yes so what I think
is interesting about what Blake said hey
I love this picture I love how he also
included Jason in it um another reason
why I love Blake but I think what he
said is interesting in that he's not
going to change the man that he is to
become the bachelor that's the line
where I'm like what does that mean what
is he saying right here what do you
think of that I know well it's Blake and
Jason both congratulating Colton on
becoming bachelor saying some nice
messages and yeah like you said Blake
said he wouldn't change the man who he
was we don't always know about all the
behind-the-scenes talks like sometimes
the bachelor is offered to someone and
they're like look no I I don't want to
go down this road I think that Blake
saying that makes me think he would have
been a really good fashion I think cuz
that's a little bit of sass right there
I know very you know tied up with a
ribbon and a bow mm-hmm so yeah um Kelly
Dunn says she was the biggest Blake fan
Debbie says I love Blake but I don't
think he's ready Mason says justice for
Blake I will say last season it really
felt like everybody wanted Peter Krause
right I still on Peter Krause Chris not
just because we have the same last name
criteria I asked Chris Harrison this he
told me that Peter Krause was not
offered The Bachelor this season so they
weren't there I don't know if they're
gonna go down that road you guys as much
as we'd love it but that very much felt
like people were so mad at wasn't Peter
I think it feels different this season I
mean I don't think people are feeling
like oh it was really gonna be this one
guy
we're disappointed it's cold you know I
think that's why I am disappointed is
because there were so many great picks
that I would have been happy with and
with guys who maybe were just a smidge
older and who I felt were a little bit
more ready I think even Ben Higgins
would have been a good choice I think
Jason would have been been a great
choice I think Blake would have been the
ultimate choice I still think Peter
Krause could have been a good bachelor
so many options and that's why I'm like
mmm-hmm
really Colleen says I did not want Blake
because I do not think he would be able
to go through and emotionally again
totally team Jason though and I feel
Colton tarnished tarnished his
reputation with paradise let's go
through I pulled a couple tweets from
you guys from bachelor nation
so tweet number one here thanks for
giving us the bachelor absolutely nobody
wanted with a boo shot from the Olympics
their tweet number two first re now
Colton it's like the producers don't
even want us to watch the bachelor
anymore it's interesting that all these
people are in agreeance with us like
this it's a little bit off the decision
here's the and you know when I brought
up the Ari thing I should say does this
feel a little bit off yes but I don't
this didn't feel like a season where
everybody would have been behind one
choice like correct it's like it's half
a dozen one the other you know you're
saying look I'm frustrated because I
think these other guys would have been
great but also if Jason had been the
bachelor there are Colton fans out there
there are Blake fans out there like
everybody would have been happy with
that or if Blake and all that so I there
didn't seem a clear choice to me and I
understand it I want to read tweet
number three here cuz this one was very
well thought out and interesting to me
she says dear producers of The Bachelor
your audience here a thirty year old
woman with nothing better to do on a
Monday night we are not interested in a
26 year old virgin with a self named
charity and no job whoa this ego-driven
Ken doll reflects our worst online dates
as opposed to an actual fantasy hmm whoo
what I would I wanted to call out there
aside from the Ken doll was an actual
fantasy this is interesting to me you
guys because on the one hand the show is
fantastical and it's a show and that's
why I think Colton as a virgin former
football player good-looking charity
starting guy is quite a story on the
other hand how much is a viewer at this
point are you wanting to watch this guy
and
oh I want this guy I could see myself
with this guy I think a lot and if you
look at their followings on social media
that's why all these women are
constantly commenting I saw today I
think it was actually on Jason's
Instagram it was a mom saying I want you
to meet my daughter and I think people
are looking at these men as these
perfect ideals of who they want to end
up with her want their daughters to end
up with and I think it's truly Colton
doesn't exactly have a full-time job he
don't have a full-time yeah he hasn't
really worked on himself and in the past
two years and maybe maybe he has I don't
want to say he hasn't but he hasn't
really had a long period of time where
he's been single and focused a hundred
percent on himself so for me like I
would never want to date somebody like
Colton and maybe that's why I'm so upset
by the choice so I think that's a fair
comment it's interesting I think the job
thing is interesting because Jason
probably had like one of the more legit
jobs of a bachelorette contestant we've
seen in a while he's a banker I think he
even said on Ben Higgins and Ashley eyes
podcasts that he spent a lot of time
really focused on his career and that's
why he felt he'd been single which we
didn't totally see that narrative come
out on the show but he's a successful
guy and you know a lot of the time we
see like I don't know jobs that maybe
you don't make all the yes sir that's
why people are also questioning his
authenticity is that we do see people
come on the show to up their
social-media followings and is that what
he's hoping to get out of this he's
almost done a million followers you can
monetize that is that what he's a
beginning end goal for Colton for Colton
what's the end goal for Colt please tell
us what you think guys we want to know
Hanna says honestly interested to see if
Colton will be able to break up with any
of these girls scares me because he has
a lot of girls to do well he broke up
with tea on Paradise last night we did
see I'm triggered though we're still
unclear on what we're doing there so
here's the thing you guys again I do
think no matter what this was not gonna
be a perfect decision and people were
gonna be up in arms anyway show creator
Mike Fleiss tweeted this this morning he
said we hear you bachelor nation I don't
know what that means what what do you
what are they gonna do with what they're
hearing my favorite part about that
tweet is looking at the threat of
comments that
came underneath it why do you think he
tweeted that I guess he wants us to feel
hurt I I don't look right places
hilarious on Twitter he says some
off-the-wall stuff that it doesn't
always I mean he's a lot of the times
being facetious guys so um I don't know
I want to know more from him on this one
what does we hear you mean I think that
these decisions you guys can sometimes
be so last-minute I remember a couple
years ago Luke Powell we interviewed him
and he was totally he told us that he
was about to get on the plane to go to
GMA to make the announcement and at that
point he was told that he was not going
to be the bachelor so these decisions
can be really last minute and really
intense and really change depending on
fan reaction in this case some spoilers
had come out there was some fan reaction
already but how much do you think that
Twitter reaction reflects the audience's
reaction and truly well we were talking
about this earlier and I do think
Twitter is a small percentage of
Bachelor viewership but I also think so
this morning my mom is in her 60s
my sister is 27 we had a group chat
going and my sister said I can't believe
Colton is the bachelor I don't want to
watch and then my mom in her sixties
said same yuck so I do think if this
isn't an overall like choice that
everybody had as their first choice no
matter how you cut it no matter if it's
on Twitter no matter if it's you know
just TV viewership ratings I think I
think overall people would have been
happy with a few other people before
Colton I am just say I didn't have a
first choice in this one I really didn't
I I would have been happy and I would
have been on board with Blake Jason or
Colton it's interesting you the we I
mean our moms are our gauges they are I
I was at this event last week and um
somebody had brought their mom to the
event and I was like I do a lot of
Bachelor reporting and she told me gosh
I thought Becca kufran was the best
Bachelorette in the history of the
franchise
I loved Becca I loved Becca ball what
was interesting to me is I wouldn't I
wouldn't say she's the best in the
history and I just thought man this
woman she's not on Twitter she's not
tweeting her opinions but she watches
the show and she has them
I think the producers also really have
to gauge you guys where they really feel
like they're getting the true pulse of
bachelor nation and it's tough for them
it's a tough and rather good
storytelling is yes I do think no matter
what people are going to continue
watching I do think people in January
we're gonna have Colton on our screens
they're all gonna be here talking about
it and that's not that's never gonna
change
Sabrina is I think of making a callback
to Peter Krause here she says it's one
thing to write your desire to be the
bachelor in a yearbook which Peter said
but it is a whole other level to go as
far as dating TIA
and probably pretend not to know her on
her season lots of you yeah also
commenting and saying you want Peter
Krause you guys I just I do think the
ship at least for the foreseeable future
hats have sailed and look if we're kind
of getting into why it is like we said
we got some source reporting this
morning I'm just gonna read some quotes
for you guys a source telling you t look
producers knew a lot of fans were into
Jason and Blake but Colton's whole
narrative was just too good to pass up
he's a virgin handsome a former football
player he runs a charity he knows how to
bring the trauma and tears he did it
over and over on both Bachelorette and
bachelor in paradise he's been a good
guy to work with producers expected some
backlash but that always happens and
they think Colton will make for a good
season
I just want to analyze one line right
there before we wrap up he knows how to
bring the drama and tears and prove that
over and over on both Bachelorette and
bachelor in paradise Annie's been a
pretty good guy to work with for them
mm-hmm Hey look you guys at the end we
kind of remember this is the TV show
okay we're all watching it we got the
commercials you do have to think about
who do you want to spend about 48 hours
a day with it's not that there's that
many hours in a day but this is somebody
that they work with see bond I'm sorry
if I'm not saying her name right says
how is Colton going to handle multiple
women for the fantasy suite and that I
do think is interesting I do think it'll
be nice to see how that plays out and I
do respect Colton for his morals I think
that's my favorite thing about him is
that he really has waited and he has
been open about it and it's been a non
popular and I think hard to talk about
topic for him and so I am here for that
and I do think back to Sean Lowe and how
he was a born-again virgin and I do
think there's something to be said about
having good morals so for that I
to say yay Colton yes you're like I'm
hesitantly yes yeah but I have to say
it's maybe been passed over how
difficult that had to be for him I can't
imagine - and even to be like he said in
the locker room and having to talk about
this with guys and you talk about that
on Bachelorette then to talk about it
again on mental to get the backlash that
he did online him being on the show he
told me was the catalyst of him and
mitting that - the first time admitting
that he'd been lying about being a
virgin - friends - family - former
teammates like so also going back and
having to tell them your truth like that
it's big and he went through a lot with
that is he ready to potentially lose his
virginity while on The Bachelor it's a
good question actually I think it's the
perfect thing to end on you guys and we
have one last little bit to play what
can we expect from here Colton is our
new bachelor I mean we think they've
never changed their minds publicly
before so I had asked Colton that men
tell all
what would it take for him to lose his
virginity what is he looking for in that
woman here's what he had to say you know
I'm waiting for the right part and let
me explain that because it sounds a
little corny it sounds a little cheesy
I'm waiting for somebody to match my
intensity someone that's going to be
into me as much as I'm into them
somebody that I'm so madly in love with
and then I can share that special moment
that's what I'm waiting for and that's
what I'm looking forward to Colin's
intense guys he is intense so Colton
Underwood is our new bachelor everybody
of course we still have a couple more
episodes of paradise to watch but we're
gonna keep on rolling on The Bachelor
train yeah I'm actually excited to see
how the other couples on bachelor in
paradise play out I love a certain Kevin
so much okay so everybody make sure to
follow ET on Twitter on Instagram and
everything and if we are gonna have tons
of new reporting and more and more
insight on bachelor for you follow miss
Katie Krauss and Lauren a lot to say
always oh thank you so much Katie thank
you for doing this with me thanks for
having me that was fun I know we're
gonna go keep going on with the group
text and keep us sending us your
thoughts you guys there's so much more
to say and I'm sure we didn't get to
everybody's as much as we would have
liked to so thanks for joining us there
will be a new episode of roses and rose'
up tomorrow morning I have a great day
today
bye guys
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]